[ __ ] you you gigantic [ __ ] oh my god
hey you still hold on I put the bike on
was going to have you're just like Bill
Schulz hey that could not be a worse
insult how are you catch I can't take
superhero [ __ ] I was just tweeting
going I can't wait to hear the
compliments I get from Jim look at this
texture on the shirt right oh wait a
second I don't want to hear anything mr.
tuxedo wearing WWE man hey man when
you're on a game show host in a dream
Center we're doing some megyn kelly
stuff for for the Olympics Akbar and I
have been doing the nine o'clock hour
with megyn kelly and so I I just -
because I needed more attention sure
what am I going to learn to fly a
helicopter wait wait the public watching
you with this but have you been we were
just on this sorry I just did we did we
did the two segments that I would think
not to thank sued it's why I yeah
because I love red I'm newly single and
so I'm desperately trying do you know
how easily you'll meet someone if you
want to big handsome famous guy in a red
suit like a dr. King yeah I'm wearing my
awesome know how to play show business
Donnie he's right he's likable he plays
the game she's not likable who Sam I
know that's what that's what I was all
Scottish oh so he quit yeah but they
didn't they say yes to giving you two
episodes yeah they said less than a they
said yes to that before they just say
yes crazy [ __ ] walks and money talks
I think I got that mixed up
you know you know you're quoting Spinal
death yeah right I well you know what
sometimes you gotta you gotta make a
move are you coming over here to Jim and
Sam no that was cold there wasn't even a
hesitation like everybody's people
always over there explain label logs
over there Kevin Brennan is a product
into enough himself right quiet chase
but it needs to be presented as the
Kevin Brennan product which is why you
can ride he wants to be put into
everywhere and a show business job he
thinks that he can do I want to do I'm
gonna do a show with Dave Lando
everything funny I think you need to
pair with that guy who there's a really
funny guy who created Chappelle's Show
psychic now he's blind he's an alcoholic
and he's a he's I like him his name is
ASCII be wonder they call him but uh
Brian McCarthy I do a shout out to him
because he's probably listen he's a big
fan of your guys thank you I have to say
I'd the amount of radio drama that you
gentlemen have witnessed over the past
couple years has been past 17 years
never been in a fight though you're
never the protagonist finally once you
go off after after decades of
provocation have I have read you you let
me tell you the cool you're right Jim
Jim is never an arguments on the air
just don't bring up DL Hughley just even
surety October I give no no I mean other
radio shows that like whether it was all
these Florida guys we used to fight with
Juan Pablo when he was in crime and
count or Mancow or [ __ ] a lexan Terry
who and I like all those guys so it's so
weird I've gotten on there shook we had
so many weird fights with other radio
shows Nancy Grace that's how he's trying
to remember I felt like in your 20s and
30s and particularly when terrestrial
radio was probably much more
was there was more of that Howard Stern
you know kill or be killed
yeah but as you've matured I think like
you know you guys have become friends
with Artie or you always will be house
over but still and yet still the drama
with the guy and now I feel bad bring
you know because people get mad at me
when I say it and I'm just a fan who
from the outside was just upset you know
people are like what did he ever do to
you I'm like well he ruined the radio
show that I enjoyed for 20 years but it
is spun off and created now more shows
but it just said that he's asking about
Artie else I say Artie could leave me
Howard
no I'll be I'll be for leave all hoping
for like blowing up for blowing up for
every you know from well you know it
sounds like he really didn't fight for
Anthony and then you know he a lien
Aidid you which you were carrying him
and now he's kind of a lean serious he
and I'll say this and to be really true
my god no you don't thinks I'm an alien
ated each other I was like throwing red
meat to the fans oh my god I know the
best part is Sam's the biggest [ __ ]
stirrer of all who just sit there going
to tell me more man I was difficult to
because we don't like you shouldn't I
can dismissed
I was far I was part of that shitty vibe
but III think I was funny I thought the
show was good even when you guys didn't
get along I enjoy working with sale I
really was funny and hope he was still
good I don't tell though you could you
could hear the tension and just the the
thing that again as a fan is a longtime
listener that I would hear is when he
would stomp on the punchlines or when he
would stomp ya on chip or when he was
like he didn't like matter if Matt saw
Opie outside be like Opie I love you I
love these pop-up videos i love i love
his anger i wanna be on your networking
piece like this
I'm trying not to get fired let me get a
red suit we'll walk around Times Square
- open Megan Kelly tomorrow they'll be
like we're a little [ __ ] for my
standards and practice you know I'm just
happy to be here with you guys being
near Megan Kelly we have them yeah so we
were two weeks for the Olympics oh we
did that's where I just came from
Mountain Kelly I'm not gonna comment on
what she smells like but I will say this
one of like immediately from the second
she saw sand again obviously there's a
lot of pressure and expectation on her
and she is the big-money person there
could not have been nicer sweeter and
came up and and just has been a dream to
work with so again you know I don't know
I've been completely impressed with her
ship show by the way to digress have you
on ship show because you like chip or
not but I caught up with like Lamar
laughs um [ __ ] Daffy Duck or
something take us out piggy boy sorry by
the way you're gonna be replaced Norton
and chip - want a show together I love
that I would love I would I would be
perfectly fine watching Jim continue to
spiral down this are this lost I know I
said it last time I was here but I know
you're a fan of Gervase but it reminds
me of extras wind your vase got the
sitcom okay oh you'll have enough of me
and he walks behind like the sitcom
thing and he's just heartbroken like
I've become this thing that I never
wanted to know and everyone loves it
yeah and you're like you know but she
got what he wanted yeah but it was like
I've what cause yeah that's what chip is
like it does it's more successful than I
am and people it's tickets sell faster
and you have people started yelling out
like started the minute based oh you
don't
the end I can't follow him oh my god
ship in the last 10 minutes overshot
ships a monster
I know he's a mom I gotta bring the wig
doll just weird doing it like Jimmy
Moore right I don't like doing them on
stage because I gotta bring them you're
like Dame Edna you're becoming this case
black out and then black out the stage
and then just put the wig on real quick
or you can see I have to figure out a
way to do I've done it once it's gonna
become like a one-man show I think
before if you turn it around and then
turn back around you which way god I
should I should [ __ ] put my all rock
and roll and they'll see my head go back
it's like kiss good good Oh chip one-man
show no no you do multiple characters
you know you have uncle Paul in there
and Ted to lose some of the audience has
got to be difficult in this climate no
because that's fake there's never been a
climate where uncle Paul was in the 60s
you could be an admitted child molester
I you know this is and this is what's so
interesting to me is even for you guys
it's serious where when I remember it
was like high voltage the virus you guys
are say anything my fault and now how
you can lose your career over a tweet
just by raping a woman yes right you got
but you do have to think of it Tony like
10 years ago we almost lost the show
because a homeless homeless charlie
almost cost us yeah oh yeah I'm not
hitting not him but the reaction is how
amazing is that too when you're like we
literally brought someone on and we're
now being held accountable for what
someone else has said on an unfiltered
radio show that is behind a paywall
that's well that's the things for people
like you do hey we're gonna be careful
and if you're not careful you get fired
and if you get fired then well you know
it took yeah there's no recourse
well the podcast is what's amazing to me
is that you have podcasts or intriguing
sits kiss-ass festival going on I just
want to irritate you Brennan so you can
go off again it's the best any [ __ ]
wins everybody why you just run for
Senate and get
you piece of sh I had never seen
anything like that one in that one move
it was Matt Iseman like like in a
nutshell you go like you [ __ ] why don't
you stop kissing everybody and he turns
around and he goes I'm just trying to
get you riled up cuz I love it so much
Kevin that be so elaborate disappointed
a woman like hella do five newly single
you have a big [ __ ] dick and I'd
pleasure that way
so I'm dating you have a big dog dick
hey I'm gonna guess Matt's an eight by
six guy yeah I'm gonna say he's an eight
by six what are the things I'm
embarrassed I'm not I can't get his name
someone just tweeted because I spilled
champagne and I got myself on the way
out here NBC paid sure and and like I
spilled the whole and so I took a
picture of like my my in it was the
crotch but then one of one of your fans
just tweeted something out it look at
the Bulge and then had it animated me
dancing over my own dick I could see I
could see having sex with somebody and
then you like go turbo dick you know
what I mean like you're pleasuring or
it's like a rocket ship you go like if
you really like you like I'm gonna
[ __ ] make this woman crazy like
though I used to be so much so much more
enthusiastic now I'm I'm just just happy
to be there anymore Kevin anything you
want to plug I'm kidding
so wait what are you doing your own
podcast now I'm sure my own MLC podcast
still but it's like listen I just don't
listen
you know how show business is you get a
lot of disrespect so I don't want to get
this respect at this point in my career
for a part-time job so I'm saying
lectures so so I don't know I didn't
know Dave Landa went then come--as were
roommates and like I didn't know all
this [ __ ] was going to he just likes
doing radio with him better than you
yeah Kevin will interpret certain things
as disrespect that are and certain
things that aren't disrespected just
because they're having other problems we
could have heard he was like him and a
lot more
I thought Alan Dow was a good compliment
to coo Mia and I think
what I'm saying is I think like better
than heaven I know I like Kevin on on
his own or with people there to rile
them up but Kevin doesn't need anyone
else you don't get me started
yeah that's why I like burning bridges
you just came in but the kind of Legion
of Anthony and Dave Landau it's Matt
listen I I tweeted I'm going on Anthony
show tomorrow and I tweeted it and then
someone goes but when's Dave Landau
coming on and Dave Lando's like I'm
coming next weekend it's like yay Dave
like a TFSA like Dave Landau's name has
been said so many times now on I hear
he's very good even live here I think
you live in Detroit or somewhere you
know we're gonna find out if he's weird
you know who's better you should get to
an hour give him a half hour give me a
half hour I'll pay for my half hour like
it's like The Bachelor yeah we should do
that I feel like David [ __ ] Anthony
Dave and Kevin right he would be the
devil though I feel like you would get
Anthony riled up in his Alex Jones mode
and Dave kind of keeps him more the
happy Jim you know Paul McCartney's life
having a miscarriage shows better with
David 1800 jokes Anthony that's the
other thing I come in and people people
are like stop with the references I'm
like no I'm not I'm a fanboy I'm but I
would say that's what I like I think
Artie's done a great job companies you
don't think so no I think he sucks a big
[ __ ] heroin day he's funny when he's
on the show though I've never seen it
I talked about Artie cuz what can he do
to me you know I mean like what can he
do like if it was Jimmy well does anyone
argues that I think I think Artie is the
first to agree
he's not long to live but what I like
about him is I think he's he's a he
brings out that machine gun Anthony that
you guys used to do gym where they're
very few people I've met like I look at
you J Moore and RD I'm right here no
you're right I love Brennan you're a
beast great but I think the machine gun
mind of back and forth
let's compliment the people that aren't
here you're great I just don't like you
know Edmund Fitzgerald are those things
where you guys could go for talking
about certain great bit they I just I
appreciate as someone who's done
stand-up and who thinks I'm clutter you
guys your minds operate at a different
speed and when it gets going as a fan
it's one of those things where you're
like how many [ __ ] times can you tag
this joke do you think you've gotta
think Matt's packing I think Matt's an
eight by six papers at the time it
allows it to get in this is this is how
a Megyn Kelly's gonna love this you're a
doctor too right yeah if you learn
little tricks at med school they won't
let me write meds anymore no I I
practiced I was doing residency I am
still licensed as a general practitioner
but nobody will authorize scripts
anymore for insurance reasons even if I
wrote them for myself they wouldn't but
if your regular doctor you can write
your own medicine
as long as it's not a controlled
substance so you couldn't write for
anything any opioids anything that's
class one controlled so you can't write
like for any pain medications anything
fun but you could write for antibiotics
or hooked on somebody Olli has a
question we will answer your question
Olli what's up yes my question was I
don't understand the conflict between
Iraq and the show like sometimes I'm not
able to listen to the entire show
because I have a job
Neal Brennan Neal I really enjoyed three
mics as well man really good shower
running man [ __ ] any time on
Sixth Avenue I'm sick of these [ __ ]
on Twitter
I'm always fight people you should I
Love You Man I just wanted to piss you
off I think you're phenomenal and that
fight with the Cuban dude was with some
of the best podcast I've ever listened
to I just wanted to piss you off the
disrespect
Oh Holly do you want to ask you about
Iraq yes I got a text from Iraq I wasn't
going to talk about on the show he
texted me yesterday in the afternoon and
he goes hey care to do dinner sometime
mmm if it's on you and I wrote back
definitely I would love to then he wrote
back cool let me know whenever is good
for you and I wrote early next week
question mark and he wrote perfect I
leave for DC on Wednesday
some Monday or Tuesday works and I wrote
yes that will be fun thank you louis c.k
disinvited me to his Super Bowl party
speaking of texts I get that he he
invited me to a Super Bowl party on the
Saturday before the Super Bowl because
he wanted Eagles fan at his party okay
so I asked my wife I go you want to go
and she goes yeah so I said I said yeah
so definitely want to go can I bring my
wife and kids because they're Eagles
fans too he goes yeah that's not cool
he goes I don't really want kids he goes
like I just got rid of my kids so then
so you have to go by yourself yeah so
then so then but my kids they were
Eagles fans they wore Eagles Jersey they
knew everything about like this party I
got it so then it so then so so and then
my wife was like she tried to get a
babysitter the kids are like no this is
this is like a big day it's a [ __ ]
family day Superbowl day so then I was
watching a game of my kids and and you
know I figure it's going to be a
competitive game it'll go to the end of
the game so I text them right before the
if I go I can I come over just by myself
he goes Knight is not here I was gonna
say Jim I don't want to put you in an
awkward position I know you got your
buds with Lois but maybe where he feels
it would be awkward for him to have
women around who maybe you know given
what's gone on recently with him who
made me feel like you know what I just
was okay me and my life and my wife was
okay say no kids yeah I said you said
can I come over by myself he said he
said come on I said I'm gonna come over
at halftime because I figured that long
halftime show I don't really care to see
it did he know I'd be just you yeah and
then he goes he goes he goes he had to
party end up being a dud nobody showed
up and he goes he goes everyone's
leaving on a half-time which I know is a
lie cuz nobody leaves anything at
[ __ ] a half-time because that's when
it that's when all the women want to
watch Justin Timberlake and then before
you know what the Nate that secondary
start maybe only had a few people there
what's that did you get him by no I
haven't talked to him I think somebody's
like this I think somebody put the
kibosh on him that like maybe he was
there didn't like me here's what I think
somebody Dave Landau here's what I think
happened I think that the party was
actually going better than some a-list
people showed up and and losing oh yeah
I kind of forgot how many really
important friends that I have and then
you text him and he's like you know a
funny part was whenever I text him like
a V text me cuz I text him last week I
go whatever just I hadn't reached out to
him so I reached out when I said I just
texted you so when I see you I don't to
say I was gonna text you you know and
then he always gets back to me like 24
hours later when I said can I come and
halftime like within the minute he's
like no right he was like no don't come
over cuz he wanted to make sure like
like no no no yeah so I think maybe I
was maybe busking maybe had a woman
there I was gonna [ __ ] block or maybe
Rachel Feinstein was there somebody who
I talk a lot of [ __ ] about and he was
just like don't don't come over
people were just leaving the party maybe
nobody leaves at halftime game I've
never know
nobody's ever left the party at halftime
history basically implied that not a lot
of people showed up and I know that I
nobody showed up cause everybody wants I
just want to see who was gonna be there
and what that look like there were
important people they didn't want you to
embarrass Tina's house is nice no I
wanna see where he lives and then if
[ __ ] goes down I could always stalk him
or [ __ ] burn his house down I said no
I might put I might give his phone
number out just to [ __ ] get even
that's smart because I thought he would
have changed his phone number after all
the [ __ ] trials and tribulations you
know anybody a number me invite you to
his Super Bowl party nope
Oh nope you know he invited no I sent a
car to the airport for Dave he did have
a party for do you so have you not
contacted Louie or is it just are you
kind of giving him space or yeah well he
wants to talk we'll talk you know when
things happen and people want to take
some time to themselves right you know
we'll talk I have no doubt we'll talk
right but yeah I think that's why I did
it when I was on last time I think you
said it I was like cuz I not running
toward the cellar and I might really
tight with him but I became more
friendly once I you know I want to
psyche kids I would go to him for advice
or when I was having problems with my
marriage
is he going to the celery's you have not
seen him no he's not been there yet so I
just want to see you I just want to see
it was at the party and then he's like
don't come over don't come up where it's
a bad idea I like dick was back you just
unnecessary my [ __ ] knuckleheaded oh
yeah have you been covering a Kim Jong
Un's sister I should cover the Olympics
hey you know we we we're doing kind of a
light-hearted stuff the nine o'clock
hour of The Today Show is much more of
the fun element not the one who owns
slaves and who is possibly related to a
dictator we don't tackle that I just
love the the backlash on it because at
first like you know she was there it
would Mike Pence in the in the box
and she was like side eyeing him and she
just looked regal I guess and so there
were all these people like there's some
people in the media that we're writing
articles about how like yes this is
North Korea's equivalent to Ivanka Trump
and she's so glamorous
and they were like all these people on
social media going yeah slay [ __ ] yes
Queen right and like it took a day for
people to point out what are you doing
she North Korea is way worse than
anything that's ever happened but she's
in charge of of enslaving Rainbow and
starving them a big deal so did we
I'm tired of five hearing about terrible
North Korea is we're friends with
[ __ ] all over the globe but all of
a sudden Kim Jong Un's a problem
isolationist Jim is coming out but you
know what I mean like we've been a
complete [ __ ] throughout history
everybody else is a [ __ ] so let's stop
pretending that we shouldn't talk to him
significantly worse they suck but so
what China stinks to [ __ ] Saudi
Arabia [ __ ] cuts heads off in the
middle of Bakuman well you your and to
see this thing of where people say okay
is this a softening of relations to have
like North and South Korea having a
women's hockey team together and then
other people saying that this is
endorsing it or condoning and again it's
what you said of well either either
we're trying to improve relations or
we're cutting it off in which case we're
you know just saying [ __ ] you were we're
trying to get rid of my friends with
Russia didn't they [ __ ] didn't they
that's a lot of controversy that's a
loaded question they fun the [ __ ] the
North Vietnamese and didn't we [ __ ]
fund Afghans who were fighting them so
let's stop pretending like October like
sometimes it just happened in the past
Wow
no cuz I you know I feel bad that I
didn't listen to the in the heyday
because I just I never was up in the
morning and I don't have a car so we
played all day we played all day that's
what I meant to say we played all day it
was a very very funny show hey yeah you
were on Celebrity Apprentice with Arnold
yes I was never Ryan I wasn't talking to
you yeah did you uh have you heard what
Piers Morgan is saying about his time
with Omarosa on Celebrity Apprentice oh
that oh I do
she said that to him I thought she was
saying that she said that about Tom know
that she would say he was gay you know
she would no he said piers went on
Tucker yesterday right Fox News and he
said that when they were doing Celebrity
Apprentice they're talking about what
I'm a roaster was saying on Big Brother
kind of trashing her and he said that
when they were on Celebrity Apprentice
together Omarosa said they should have a
showmance and he was like what are you
talking about and she was like we should
we should have sex like for the show
right and then we can do well here we
can have a spin-off show we can do all
this calculator and he was like no I
don't want to have sex with you right
gave the sandy came retort which is
pretty gay yeah but that was Trump era
yeah I met Omarosa at at a reality event
and she's very nice and my buddy is
working on Celebrity Big Brother where
she is right now and and just says this
is a woman who has a plan she's going in
there she's got a book coming out and
she didn't go in there randomly she was
you know she just gotten out of the
White House it was a week yeah from the
White House to it's a really big brother
and that's where we live and nobody's
nobody scratching their heads at it
well you don't mean it's just like of
course yeah yeah it was she was in the
White House yeah now she's got a big
brother Ed Morris I'm not being
holier-than-thou obviously I went on
apprentice because nobody I wanted
people to know who I was and you didn't
work in the why I did not work in the
White House a week before I mean were
you on apprentice I was aren't most
recent in the last season that clearly
you know I I freaking loved him question
I I tend to give the benefit of the
doubt like I've been a dick a lot of
times and I'm sure I can imagine you're
a dick all the time right I told you do
not help a lady cross the street one
time you know what's wrong
you you meet someone and they're an
[ __ ] to you like your big unit right
he wouldn't take a photo with you but
you remember Gary oh I know it's a big
yes bring it up but but it's one of the
things where you know sometimes just
some the worst but I'm also like who
knows maybe he just found out you know
his mom had cancer or something so I'm
like unless someone is a repeated
[ __ ] to me sure I kind of tend to
give the benefit you give them one shot
at being a dick because it could be as
bad because I you know I'm sure there
are lots of people who would say I've
been you know a moody little [ __ ] and
they're probably right but I think I you
know you try modi's happy and joyous
[Laughter]
religion you know like when I went on
apprentice I knew I was the least famous
person so right there was a thing of
like you know Vince Neil's there from
Motley Crue and at one point he and Jon
Lovitz are yelling at me or Boy George
is yelling at me but I'm also like yeah
you've been famous for 30 years you
played you know sold a hundred million
records sure or they know you've been
rocking all over town like we made them
wait for I'm a Boy George wait for an
hour for a shoot and it was just because
you know you're you're these tasks you
actually have to do the tasks and it
actually is harder work than you would
think and so you're trying to organize
it and Boy George is having this tantrum
and you just kind of are like well am I
gonna go no you know what [ __ ] you you
Divo are you gonna go okay first of all
I know I'm on camera right and I know
I'm the easiest one to get voted fired
yes so you're kind of like I can put up
with that so nobody really got under my
skin because you also know it's TV you
know a dime in reality but who sticks in
your craw have you ever hit it have you
ever hit a woman no but I did have my
nose broken by one who gets your goat
all right what happened yes I keep
breaking which it was a spine a girl's
penis Jim a girl I was dating who I'd
met on like I went through a phase where
when I was younger when I was internet
dating and not looking for a
relationship I was looking for fun whoa
and I met
girl who was fun and we were having a
good time and then she found out I was
still on the service just but I wasn't
using I'm like I'm I'm fine having fun
with you she thought you're cheating on
me so she starts swinging at me and
smashed my nose and with the end of
relationship yeah Wow can't you showed
her that you have no activity I tried to
on the app I tried to but she's like I
don't believe she was busy punching you
in the face
she's what she is manic no is there
[ __ ] crazy punch you in the face
she's threatened me so many times it's
never hit you now she's she's like
pushed me you know I mean she's never
like she's like me I don't know I mean
she they're [ __ ] nuts man happy
Valentine's Day honey yeah but they're
real crazy yeah what are the things that
gets my god I think are the comics
I think you've become more social
justice warriors after kind of having
urn you talk about Jim specifically
totally right you know people who don't
support other comedians freedom of
speech because it's you know it's the
Sarah Silverman it's the thing of either
everything's fair game or nothing's fair
game I think and to to say well you
could say this you can't say this or you
could take because you have a like you
can't say that Kevin no I have Hispanic
wife oh okay now you can say you can't
even that you can't even give you a pass
and I think it's one of those things of
you know where we can't really say if I
am I am checking at West Coast comics
like with all their political [ __ ]
like you know has it changed no you see
these West Coast like Patton Oswalt like
you know come on man
[ __ ] your Keebler Elf you know what I
mean like he's like just all this
[ __ ] sjw right and and you know and
then I was just watching cumbia you know
and I'm drinking a kool aid a little bit
over there to watch a lot of cumin
and no he said you know what sarah said
she wants to eat her [ __ ] aborted
baby and it's like it's just it's just
pathetic to me you know like talk tough
that's why I said he's [ __ ] trolls on
Twitter like just meet me I'd rather
just fight a [ __ ] good fight instead
of all this like I like all this like
I'm a tough guy on Twitter and it's like
I'm everybody's a tough guy there's like
it's yeah it's embarrassing today but
but I also think they some of the people
half the people like they would say that
and then you'd go oh [ __ ] you and they'd
be like oh and actually I'm a huge fan I
just wanted to get your attention and
you're like I don't know that all these
people who are trolling always believe
what they're saying so much as they know
the negative responses tend to garner
more from you through Kevin like a try I
know I hope people will troll you
because they know you you know someone
says something nice you know Sarah
Silverman right Sarah Silverman is a
[ __ ] college dropout and and singing
the know she's got a political [ __ ]
expert she didn't go to Harvard [ __ ]
and she's over man
do you think she's been out of college
long enough yeah she could have done
some reason he could you say Harvard
School of Government yeah what's the
school of government land of said he
would have [ __ ] any way to clean that
up because you're famous casseras famous
all these people are like like I said
I'll see Sarah tweet and within like 39
seconds she has like like 2,000 likes
I'm like do they sign up you can you
sign up to automatically like well of
somewhat straight format because
somebody yes like Sarah's an expert
Sarah Sarah knows what she knows like
most people like self I educated they
know what they know they don't know they
don't know the different broad sprek
that's broad spectrum of like
intelligence right you're a doctor you
know what I mean you have to kind of
know different aspects of I'm right
because I know one side inside and out
Pat Naz but she's just explaining her
opinion who cares she's a [ __ ] she
[ __ ] her way to the top
I wish I could do Dice Clay oh but who
Kelly if she says thank you people agree
with her like I don't agree with her
tweets on I don't care what she said I
raise they don't as long as they don't
then condemn other comedians yeah like
have your opinion but don't come after
someone else for something they've done
because I think I wish I have my [ __ ]
boxing gloves on I would would you with
a [ __ ] right cross I just want to see
how he reacts when when he gets really
mad punch I just slap if Kevin Brennan
punched you in the face right now would
you hit him back I got punched in the
face for a TV show and it was a boxer as
like a hundred 19 pound professional
boxer it was like one of those it was it
was a super slow-mo camera so there's
like an image of me getting punched and
it hurt did you get knocked down no I
did he jabbed can't
ether a jab I think he kind of pulled it
a little bit you know you know again I
have rheumatoid arthritis like you know
if you have whatever it takes to get the
[ __ ] after I have to rotate around I
have no neck flexibility and I'm sorry
too and he's like I'll break I might
break your neck if I really punch you I
have no neck flexibility I notice I've
injured mine but have you heard where my
body attacks itself causing inflammation
tends to be a joint so like neck and
back I'm sorry it's the one part of me
that still gets stiff Kevin my
grandfather has rheumatoid arthritis but
the only reason I know is because when
my grandmother died my mom he's not a
sensitive man my mom like you know I
like him already we flew to you know
Detroit where they live and my mom went
to talk to her dad and she goes and they
don't have a good relationship really
but she goes no he wasn't around at all
clearly when she was growing up but she
goes and she goes hey Dad how are you
doing and he goes well okay you know I
got the rheumatoid arthritis and we're
like your wife of 60 years just died
okay but he was he was not doing that
well because his arthritis was good for
him
and then he went to the funeral with a
blue tooth that is here the whole time
oh my god explains your mom being the
complete opposite your hair she's the
complete opposite these are references
family she never had yeah understandable
yes
I'm sure she's happy with you I would I
mean how could you not be you know what
you haven't you have a grandkid like my
my
couple times a week my brother had a
baby and my mom so they were I have a
brother it was so three my dad my
brother and I growing up with my mom and
I think she was just kind of felt missed
the female presence and so now had my
brother having a wife and then having a
baby girl my mom couldn't be happier
having a grandchild
oh yeah I'm sure your mom's problem yeah
it's amazing
we're invisible now oh absolutely it's I
don't get spoiled anymore it sucks